let's fix these uh livestocks
i just did the uh open mic
at the heckle mic thanks for coming you
did it
oh it took care of somebody yeah
which is the same thing
that's pretty big
as you know
oh my god what is that stuff is that
essential oils
which parts or to your shoulder these
aren't those products
i haven't can i just try to use it he
said how how does one because
[Music]
i mean i was enjoying the way it felt on
my neck it was relieving some pressure
seeing you use it makes me
actually need no i think we need to use
my wipes after each turn yeah i need to
wipe it down
or he's where are you squeezing so yeah
so much rubbing i gotta get in there man
yeah i gotta get in the ramp
it's just such a genius like it it
always feels so like smart
i just lost the privileges see what look
at how he's doing it i think it looks
aggressive i think it would hurt me
how does that look to an uneducated
person i don't know nobody have to be
educated
experienced i guess in uh whatever that
is what is it called i think all of us
are educated here except for me i'm not
only on edgy like i didn't finish
college tell them
yeah i was gonna ask a question then
it's live
did you guys see the new season of too
hot to handle
no what the [ __ ] is that it's probably
some reality trash tv
yeah
yeah let the games begin it's two
different seasons about like people who
can't who have sex with one person every
single night
and they're all like hot
and then they have to not have sex for
like a month now they're a little nine
fees dude that sounds like some puritan
like sexual abstinence it like it forces
them to like one thing you don't want
real quick so i throw them in
all right so what does that mean for me
now uh that's nothing yet we're just
saying it goes first what'd you get
snickers
five was i got nine
see i like
i find an area where there's a lot of
room to squish down and then i create
leverage and i just go really hard and
then i move around so that it cracks
oh that's the new this sounds like a
good way to just break your neck i just
try to like massage like worse
you seem like you don't even know how to
operate a gun
that's maybe well that's probably a bad
thing when a [ __ ] gets real at the post
so you don't yeah i do not offer i have
a 20 gauge under my bed that i know how
to operate and that's all that matters
right there's a 20 yeah
i need to buy some ammunition you you
get 12-gauge
weapon yeah the 20-gauge will just the
scare tactic of this basic it's like oh
it'll hurt you know and that's all i
need to do and then that's what if
there's not that [ __ ] actual hammer i
have oh yeah
shotgun